he was so obsessed with his lizards all
he wanted was to photograph the lizards
he never wanted to put me in a close-up
he photographed everybody else in
close-up but not me
but I remember to my relief a few fans
were there and they said can we please
have a picture with you and they got
right there and said sure honey and we
took a great picture again I said you
see burner some people do want me in a
close
[Laughter]
[Music]
moonstruck I had made a movie called
Peggy Sue got married cher had seen that
movie and she immediately said I saw
Peggy Sue got married and I thought I
was your performance was like watching a
two-hour car accident or a train wreck I
was kind of amazed that she saw it that
way and also that she wanted to work
with me as the result of seeing a
two-hour car accident but that she
wanted me to play ronny cammareri and it
was deeply flattered because I was still
am a fan of cher there's a moment where
I raised the wooden hand and I I said I
lost my hand I lost my bride and I think
I got that idea from watching Fritz
Lang's Metropolis I think there's a
moment in that movie I'm not a Harper
censored and it's been a while since
I've seen it but I do believe I was
inspired by a moment in that movie when
the doctor ripped off the glove from his
metallic Han and he did that and I
wanted to be kind of German
expressionistic like the old metropolis
movie by Fritz Lang when I read the
script
the fantastic John Patrick Shanley
script
I somehow responded to it like Beauty
and the Beast and I had been a big fan
of Jean Cocteau's Beauty and the Beast
Jean morees performance I mean as the
Beast and he would talk like that in a
French in French fighting me hold he's
almost a shame arrhythmia oh I wanted to
speak like that because I had responded
to the script that way and about two
weeks into production I went home for
the holidays and I got a call from the
director Norman Jewison who said Nick
the dailies aren't working I want you to
drop the Jean Marais this this voice
you're doing is not working and I
dropped the Jean Marais but what's
fascinating is when John Patrick Shanley
and I talked about the script he said
the original title was not moonstruck it
was the wolf and the bride so I was I
think I was tapping into something from
a screenwriter
Raising Arizona H I'm McDonough to me
was like a living cartoon I saw him as
Woody Woodpecker and so much so that I
even put the thrush muffler tattoo you
know the woodpecker with the cigar and
red feathers went back and the Wynn is a
tattoo for H I'm ik Donna put it on the
characters arm that would rub my hair
and so static electricity would make it
lift up so that I was like Woody
Woodpecker and would look like what do
you woodpecker
I must have auditioned for that movie
about 20 times Joel and Ethan
they would laugh every time but then
they would say during the audition we're
laughing we can't stop laughing but we
don't know why we're laughing so there
was a little bit of trepidation and then
they cast me and I was thrilled because
I knew right away when I had read the
script that this was gonna be a winner
that this could really be something
special about a week into rehearsals
Joel took me aside he said you know I
could have cast Kenan Kozma in this bar
or I could have cast this thing I said
well why did you cast me yeah and that
that stopped that conversation Ethan was
a great audience Hugh just he was always
laughing in the back in the corner he'd
be laughing at every scene and that was
actually a terrific experience for me
and I that's why I first coined the
phrase I'm getting that super8 feeling I
used to make movies with my brother in
the backyard when we were children and
we had a super 8 camera that my father
gave us and we would make movies and
that super 8 feeling I've often said is
the feeling where you're making a movie
simply because you love the movie you're
not doing it for money you're not doing
it for awards you're doing it simply
because you love the story you're
telling and the filmmaking experience
itself and I remember Joel said I said
I'm getting that super 8 feelings and
well that's good that's good let's go
with the keep that going leaving Las
Vegas when I read that script I thought
it was the coolest relationship I'd ever
seen even though one was an alcoholic
and the other was a prostitute I thought
there was so much compassion in that
relationship and I had seen all the
great alcoholic performances ray Milan
and Lost Weekend Jack Lemmon and days of
wine and roses Dudley Moore and Arthur
or Kris Kristofferson and stars born all
brilliant and I took something from all
of them from Kristofferson I took that
beautiful smile even though he was
drinking himself to death that smile
from Dudley Moore the idea that he
didn't know how to modulate his volume
but it wasn't until I saw Albert Finney
and under the volcano I saw him walk
through the streets of Mexico and I went
that guy's really drunk and I asked
about it I asked Mike because Mike had
worked with Albert and I said was he
really drunk and it got back to me that
Albert's you know you tell Nick that I
would take a swig and I would spit it
out just so I get the taste of it I
wasn't really druggers okay cool and and
then my cousin Roman Coppola he said you
should go hire Tony Tony Dingman who was
at that time you know I'm very drunk
I've also a poet hire him and just watch
him and have him be your drinking coach
so I had Tony on the set with me all the
time the poor guy he'd be curled up in a
fetal position on her in my in my
trailer as I'm playing bongos because I
was trying to play bongos they get some
kind of syncopated rhythm some sort of
music for the character but I would
watch him he would say the most poetic
drunken things like you do not kick the
bar you lean in to the bar because it's
not vino veritas it's in vino veritas he
would just spout these things out of
course I put them all in the movie
because it's not vino veritas it was a
four-week shoot thank God it was only a
four word shoot because there were a
couple scenes where I really wanted to
be hammered because I wanted to be out
of control and have them photograph that
so I could reach that kind of
credibility of authenticity of what I
saw on the streets of Mexico and under
the volcano the scene that comes to mind
is the casino
scene where I say I am his father and I
flip the table and have a blackout I
didn't know I was gonna go there I knew
I wanted something extraordinary to
happen and they kept in they put it in
the movie to the 16-millimeter I would
say that it is phenomenal for film
performance when you have a camera that
big or that big and it's 35 millimeter
cameras with these lenses like that in
your face that is something you have to
try to get past you have to be bold with
that but it's not something you really
want to think about when you have a
camera that's that big they're just
flowing around anyone can be a great
actor and it catches the most minimal
nuances and you're not even thinking
about the cameras so it's effortless I
can tell you specifically that I made
that movie saying to myself I'm never
gonna win an Academy Award nobody wants
to make this movie and because I wasn't
gonna win an Oscar I said I don't care
let's just make the movie let's be down
and dirty let's be you know punk rock or
jazz rock or whatever it was and so it
was completely unexpected which is to
say I'm deeply thankful I think gary
oldman once said the sound of applause
is not to be ignored you know and I am
thankful that that happened but I was
totally a surprise Cameron Poe was
really a fantasy of as a young boy in
Long Beach California growing up skinny
kid who read Incredible Hulk comics you
know who wanted to not be bullied and
you know wanted to be Cameron Poe that
was my fantasy of who I wanted to be of
who you know I I would have liked to
have been at that age so I was kind of
creating a character that was like the
uber version of myself if I was a
southern badass you know that's who I
that was my expression of that even
though I'm not bad it was an interesting
set to be on it was a completely
testosterone addled set everyone doing
push-ups and chin-ups and trying to see
who could won faster and it was always
some sort of competition happening on
that set of machismo
I think the genius if
is a genius of that movie and I think
Jerry Bruckheimer's genius I would say
is that he was he knew how to make
formula pictures you know
extraordinarily commercial but he came
at it with an independent edge I mean
all the actors in that movie
people like ving and John Malkovich and
you know Buscemi we're up we all came
out of Hindi movies so that was kind of
his I think Jerry's true genius with
that they saw faceoff was really the
direct result of another movie I made
called vampire's kiss which I considered
my laboratory and in that movie I really
wanted to find a way to express again my
kind of German expressionistic dreams
aka you know like Alan Oz ferati or
Calgary where these actors were doing is
extraordinary phases of body language
that was not necessarily natural but
expressionistic that's my favorite movie
I've made by the way and I knew that I
had to find a vehicle that would allow
me to do that where there was some
mechanism of truth or reality in that
the character was losing his mind so his
behavior his body language his facial
expressions were also the result of a
man who was having a nervous breakdown
so therefore I could become very
stylistic so a lot of the the body
language and facial expressions went
into faceoff but John Woo who is also
you know very operatic and musical
extraordinary filmmaker he showed me his
movie bullet in the head I knew once I
saw that movie where I could go in terms
of style and in terms of right up
against the edge you know operatic if
you will emotion and so a lot of the
stuff I discovered on vampire's kiss
which I enjoyed I could pull it into a
movie that would later become a
mainstream and commercial film so I was
like a dream come true
I here I was doing these kind of
abstract you know ontological facial
expressions and in a movie that was
gonna make a ton of money which I was
thrilled with the results we had the
luxury of looking at each other's
dailies I would see what John would do
and then he would see what I would do
playback and then we could find ways to
mirror one
match it when I first reported for work
on that movie it was the stuff I did in
the priests attire like the the whole
head banger head rolling stuff and the
clapping and the grabbing of the young
lady and all the crazy stuff about
Handel's Messiah and I know John saw
that and he was so we're gonna go with
that kind of act
[Music]
but really he he got to play cast or
more than I did I was only caster for
like that once the credits were over I
was done playing caster and then he just
took it and ran with it for the rest of
the movie one day I would like to do a
movie where I'm casting through the
whole movie bringing out the dead wasn't
too hard to act in that movie I think it
was about a not a full six months but
running close to six months all at night
and paramedics you know this particular
paramedic was working entirely at night
dealing with exhaustion he was
approaching burnout I would work all
night and then I would still get on a
plane for my weekend visit with my then
child son Westen at the time so I could
have my weekend visits with him then get
back on a plane go back and report for
duty so needless to say I was very tired
but all that just went into the
character I went on a few ride alongs
which was I don't know if it was the
most ethical thing to do cuz but I
wanted to do the research Hell's Kitchen
Manhattan that whole area at that time
was not one we were filming was not the
same thing as it was when Connelly wrote
the book or his experience it was a much
more dangerous and scary place I think
whoever was mayor cleaned it up pretty
good but I went on the ride alongs and I
do recall one kid african-american kid
got shot through the ass and I'm in the
back of the wagon you know and he still
got gum in his mouth and you know I'm
worried he's gonna choke and the other
Primerica like injecting him and getting
him ready and prepping him and I just
give me a girl it took the gum out of
his mouth because I thought he was gonna
choke but he's looking at me you know so
I don't know if he thought he was
hallucinating or what but he recognized
me it was just very strange anyway I did
call Marty I said Marty I had some
pretty interesting experiences but it's
not the same Hell's Kitchen that
Connelly wrote about but I did learn
about a few things that were pretty
hardcore you know
adaptation Wow an adaptation when people
say I love Donald I get jealous because
I don't remember playing Donald I was so
into the Charlie Kaufman headspace and
Charlie and I would spend hours
interviewing I would interview Charlie a
tape recorded all the interviews well
I'm gonna let you do this if you promise
it never goes anywhere and I said
Charlie I'm gonna light them on fire I
promise you and I did
I poured kerosene I lit them on fire
they're all gone but I went through all
the motions with Kaufman I said well let
me see you get angry
what do you like me he was a good actor
actually Charlie Kaufman is a very good
actor it was twice as much dialogue as
everybody else and I would go to set and
if I got out of bed on that side and I
was in a good mood I said let's start
with Donald today and if I woke up the
next day and I got on a bed on that side
and I was in a bad mood and crank it say
let's let's start with Charlie today so
we sheets the whole thing one way this
is either Charlie or Donald and then
take what I did put an earpiece in my
ear and do playback well I looked at a
tennis ball on a stand like that over
there you know and imagine I'm either
Charlie O'Donnell and talking to one
another it was probably the most
acrobatic challenge as a thespian I've
ever had and I'm not even sure I could
do it again I I I'm not sure I could but
anyway it's cold for my killer to have
this modus operandi because at the end
when he forces the woman who's really
him to eat herself
he's also eating himself to death I've
been saying Marlboros I don't know what
that word means I've written myself into
my screenplay that's kind of weird huh
you know Meryl was great and Chris was
great and you know they got their Oscars
but cool it was just it's all good there
you know they were brilliant in the
movie but it was the most challenge
anything I've ever done national
treasure
I did not expect national treasure to be
ahead I did know that I was working with
a high school classmate named Jon
Turteltaub who was the director the two
of us were crack-ups I mean in high
school we were always making jokes and
cracking each other up and he got the
lead role in our town and I got the
crummy part of constable Warren and he
never let me forget it and I got my
revenge when I got on the cover of GQ
and John admitted to me and I went to
the store and there you were on the
cover of GQ
how come Nick's on the cover of GQ and
I'm not on the cover of GQ was that kind
of relationship high school kids but
that that kind of fun and and
playfulness carried through with the
making of national treasure so I think I
really have to credit John for the humor
and the success of the movie and Jon
Voight actually said you know turtle
tops terrific he he knows how to make a
souffle
one false move this whole thing is gonna
fall apart but somehow Jon Turteltaub
managed to put it together in a way that
was delectable and delicious and but I
have to attribute the success of that
film to him Bad Lieutenant corner Paul
knew
I was the big fan of both burners and
Klaus Kinski and having seen all of
their movies I knew not unlike what I
knew when I saw bullying ahead with John
Woo where I could go with performance
and I really wanted to challenge Verner
I wanted to be the California Klaus
Kinski I wanted to go all out and even
scare him at times to get to the core of
that character and I remember I had this
vial of something called inositol which
is like a saccharine substitute it looks
like coke but it's not it's sugar really
or a sweetener and I would psych myself
up you know and I'd snort this and try
to get into the headspace and Vernon
everyone's kind of getting a little
flipped out about my psychic process to
get this seen because I'm going nuts and
I'm the high on coke and burner was like
now Nikolaus lot is in that vial and I'm
and this is right before action and I'm
now the California Klaus Kinski I don't
have to say it's not coke you know but
because it's gonna break the imagination
because I'm psyching myself up I was
completely dry on that movie I wasn't
drinking I wasn't nothing there's an
impressionistic performance but
nonetheless he broke my concentration
and I say get a coke get off my set yeah
New Orleans this is my city just
everybody was like that and then they
said action and it was I was the guy I
was in the headspace I'll take 25
percent of it though I'm God means you
get above price that's one way of
looking at it the other is you get to
keep 75 percent and not go to prison for
the rest of your life
man
panis is really a visionary he's a
genius he's not like anybody else who
makes a movie once every eight years he
his black rainbow movie I didn't sleep
for a week after I saw that originally
he wanted me to play Jeremias and I was
playing army of one at that time I was
in Vancouver I had long white hair hair
and long white beard and he said to me I
want you to play Jeremiah sand and I
said well why he says because I you know
I think the characters like a cloud
California Klaus Kinski he literally
said that and I said well I am the
California Klaus Kinski but I don't want
to play Jeremiah sand I want to play red
and he said well this is a movie about
age vs. youth and I don't see his rep
because of that at that point I did look
like father time I was fully you know
Gandalf so it didn't work out and then
about a year later and Elijah Wood was
the one who brought us together and I'm
thankful for Elijah that he did that but
he came up with the idea that I should
play red and red was a character that I
I wanted to portray because I felt I do
have the power of imagination but I also
felt I had the life experience to play
red and have you been through love and
loss and going through you know what was
going to be my third divorce and also my
father had passed away and that really
stuck with me and so I knew I had the
emotional content to play red because
red is really a being who's contending
with loss loss of love and it's
interesting because if you look at
Paris's notes about the picture he was
contending with the same thing not in
terms of the romantic love but more in
terms of familial love and loss so we
were in step the whole way and I think
we we found a way to calibrate the
amount of emotion when and where and
then also in terms of body language in
terms of the fight sequences before red
drinks the kind of supernatural skull
juice you know hallucinogen if you will
that transforms on red is much more
ferocious as a fighter and we thought
about Bruce Lee and I showed him in an
old take of Bruce Lee and Enter the
Dragon where the camera goes I'm really
quick and he snaps something it's like
that luck you know that fantastic his
big eyes and so I want us to try and get
shot you know and that scene we got it
where the camera came right in so I was
thrilled with that but then after the
skull juice panels wanted more to be
like Jason from Friday the 13th to which
I thought because I'm not I don't really
watch slasher films I did watch the one
he wanted me to see but I thought more
like the ancient golem not the one in
Lord of the Rings the ancient golem the
Jewish golem which was a statute on to
life so red red becomes more of a
monolith if you will so all those little
details were planned out with panels
together we we formed
[Music]